Hi, I'm LeVar Burton and
we all love to be read to,
especially children but
I believe adults need
to be read to and millennials especially
because their lives are so stressful.
Today's selection is The ABC's of 2017
written by Tracy Clayton and Heben Nigatu.
A is for alternative facts,
what adults now call lies.
B is for Beyonce
and the apples of her eye.
C is for contouring,
YouTube's big obsession.
D is for debt, which a
lot of folks are left in.
E is for emoji, our
modern romance language.
F is for fidget spinner because
even our kids are anxious.
G is for GIF
and yes, that's really how you say it.
H is for our heroes who
continue to slay it.
I is for impeachment on everybody's minds.
J is for The Juice,
who's loose another time.
K is for the KKK
who feels safe to come out of hiding.
L is for love is love is love
to counter the hatred and fighting.
M is for millennials who
just can't do anything right.
N is for no, a word that
helps us fight the good fight.
O is for the oh, crap,
what we say when we hear the news.
P is for Putin, one of
Trump's most trusted boos.
Q is for questions, which
we'll ask until we croak.
R is for reading, which
is how we stay woke.
S is for sorry, not sorry,
the cry of the unapologetic.
T is for the trash this world becomes
if we continue to let it.
U is for universal health care,
which we shouldn't have
to move to Canada for.
V is for voting rights.
You'd think we were in 1964.
W is for the wonder women
who punch, lasso and kick.
X is for our ex-boyfriend, Obama,
on Instagram making us sick.
Y is for you still getting up every day
and doing it again tomorrow.
And z is for the zoo
this world has become.
Please come back, Obama.
(whooshing)
Damn, this is depressing as (beep).
(hip hop music)
(bell dinging)
(whistle blow)